de planification qui vont enfin aboutir
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle Honor et vous allez dire
que je suis le cliché de l'élève moderne
j'ai ouvert le club de karaté du lycée
j'ai mis en place une banque alimentaire
pour les personnes défavorisées et tout
ça sans que mes notes en pâtissent pour
moi tout ce qui compte au lycée c'est ce
qui vient après le lycée et je ne vise
rien de moins que la plus grande
université du monde au nord mon élève la
plus prometteuse j'ai un contact auprès
du Comité des administes
que j'envisage de recommander
je pense la corde de sol excusez-moi
vous avez bien dit l'une des quatre
ambition il peut s'agir que de trois
personnes mais un seul représente une
véritable menace Michael dicniquer il
faut que ces résultats dégringols d'ici
les examens c'est quoi le projet et
Michael tu voudrais bien réviser avec
moi
d'accord pas de problème
la première phase de mon plan de
bataille déstabiliser l'intello quelque
chose ne va pas mieux de se mettre au
travail parce qu'il va me falloir une
bourse n'a pas peur de casser le bout à
force
ils grandissent si vite
[Musique]
de le comprendre personne fait attention
à moi
je pense que
qu'il me plaît
c'est juste un obstacle de plus à
surmonter j'écraserai tout ce qui se
dresseront sur mon chemin
j'ai l'impression que tu fais semblant
je veux pas lui faire de peine mais je
peux pas la jouer
[Musique]
mettre une raclée
aujourd'hui
pour nous concerts c'est comme un tweet
mais mauvais pour la planète je vais le
twitter ça je crois